[Music]
hey y'all
welcome to tomes of terror my little
humble book review show
going for the big dogs this time this is
actually the first time even though i've
read most of stephen king's
[ __ ] over well i don't know if i'd say
most but a large portion of his books
i've read over the years
but i haven't read like my reading of
his newer stuff has been kind of
sporadic so this is actually the newest
book of his
that i read and this is called
revival this came out in 2014. i think
prior to this the newest one of his that
i had read was
dr sleep which came out the year before
this 2013 and i actually watched that
or i actually read that like before the
movie came out so i could compare the
two things
i think prior to that like the newest
stuff i had read was i think i read 11
22 63 i read douma key
i read um uh what was that other one
under the dome i think that was 2009. so
you know i know he's written like a [ __ ]
ton of new stuff and i haven't really
like kept up with it
but you know that's not to say yes i do
prefer his older stuff but
this one it's kind of interesting how i
came across this because
i hadn't really been following when one
of his new books comes out like you know
i'll go get it from the library or i'll
read it or whatever
but it's like it's not kind of like oh i
gotta go get it right now because
there's like a zillion books on my
tbr by tons of other authors and you
know so i don't keep up with
his new stuff coming out as much as i
used to so i was actually in a
secondhand bookstore the same place that
i got
uh the last novel that i reviewed which
was others by james herbert
and i just saw this one like sitting on
top of a bookshelf and it's like brand
new like hardback and everything like
that and i was just kind of like oh man
it's like
stephen king and i hadn't even heard of
it so i was like okay 2014.
and i thought what the hell i'm gonna
buy it i didn't even read what it was
about or anything like that because i
said you know it's [ __ ] stephen king
right it's like it's at least gonna be
worth reading
so i did i picked it up and decided i
was gonna sit down and read it and i
gotta say
this book is was pretty [ __ ] good
you know what i mean i like i said i
went into it not knowing
at all what to expect as i said i have
read some of his more recent stuff but
not a lot and i will say that
uh dr sleep again which was you know
prior to this the most recent one of his
that i read i didn't i liked it but i
didn't love it
and the movie was good too and
everything but it's like i didn't love
the novel
this one i think i kind of loved it
because the thing about this one
the thing that's great about this book
is that
it's kind of like the best
possible meeting of his more
newer i want to call it like his more
like psychological so more like 11 22
63 was where it was just kind of like
this
where he's talking more about life in
general just like the wake you know
because he's getting older now and
you never per you know since his
accident and everything like that he's
been writing a lot about
um the 60s and things like that so this
has
that aspect to it but then it also has
like the horror [ __ ] it also has
elements of frankenstein in there it has
like a lot of elements of lovecraft in
there like particularly toward the end
um and i wasn't really expecting and i
really liked the way it went also has
some kind of ray br
bradbury like something wicked this way
comes a type of vibe to it
which was also really cool and i liked
at the beginning it's almost kind of
like
an homage to all of the horror that he
read growing up
and it's also kind of like a really
heartfelt
meditation on aging loss of faith
you know what's going on in the
afterlife you know how grief can warp
people's perceptions
um you know forbidden knowledge that
kind of stuff
so it's so i really really really got
into it
so the story of this one like i said i'm
not i don't know if i'm gonna like spoil
it out right but you know it came out
several years ago
and as with anything i never say i'm
gonna spoil it because i don't really
script these obviously so i don't like
know if i'm going to or not it just
depends when i get there
but so i'm always just kind of like at
the beginning you know me
if you want to read it without having
any preconceptions or even any idea what
it's about because that's how i went
into it i just said oh it's stephen king
this is one i hadn't heard of it came
out in 2014 so i just picked it up and
read it
without knowing at all where it was
gonna go and
i kind of liked that about it because
through the whole thing i just really
had no idea
what direction this was gonna take so i
may spoil some [ __ ] for you
like i said if you haven't read it or if
you just want to go into it blind as
always you know might want to turn this
off and come back later
uh you know and we can kind of talk
about it then please excuse my voice is
a little froggy i have like
a bit of a sore throat for whatever
reason that i woke up with but i'm going
to try and
push through it so this book it
basically
follows almost the entire life
of our main protagonist whose name is
jamie morton
and it's all from his point of view so
this is all in the first person
so jamie morton we start out in the 60s
when he is a little kid
and he's six years old and basically the
book like follows him
throughout his life until he's like in
his early 60s when he's
telling this story like telling about
this stuff that happened
so when he's a little kid he's living in
uh
his tent a little town in harlemain and
the town
gets a new methodist minister or pastor
or whatever it is that they call them
named pastor jacobs charles jacobs is
the guy's name
so he's very young kind of like a hip
guy every and he's
like really really nice and everybody
loves him and he takes particularly in
particular interest in um jamie not in a
creepy way or anything because that's
kind of how i thought this was going to
go
because i was like normally nowadays you
read a story where like a pastor is like
hey little boy let's see and you know
it's it's going to go in one direction
but it it doesn't go in that direction
at all
so i thought that was kind of
interesting because he's like playing
with the expectations there
but yeah so this guy is just like a
totally nice guy he moves to
this little town with his family he has
this beautiful wife and this little
this cute little son that everybody's uh
you know just thinks is adorable and you
know carry him around everywhere
and everything is super happy now the
pastor
is also real into electricity like it's
his hobby
so he builds his own [ __ ] like he builds
his own batteries like he's like hey i
can build
you know air conditioners he can build
things and you know so that's kind of
like his hobby has like a little shed
where he works on things
and he also does little things for the
church like he has
this little this little jesus that he
has like a little battery in it that he
built that kind of
like looks like it walks across water
like it's going like on this little
track or whatever
so right away we're hinting at one of
the themes of the book which is
almost kind of like religion as
sham i guess um because there's a lot of
carny kind of stuff that happens later
and he's kind of drawing a parallel
between
all of these miracles um and stuff that
you know from a religious context and
kind of carny tricks or magic tricks
so he's kind of drawing a lot of that as
well which like i said that kind of gave
me of something wicked this way comes
vibe so electricity is like a big
theme in this book which is why there's
like a lightning bolt on the front which
totally makes sense also i will say
right here that i love the title
revival is like the perfect title
for this book because it has
over the course of the story it has
multiple meanings
at some point it does refer to like a
literal like tent revival like a
religious
type of thing but it also refers to
revival from the dead
it also refers to revival from
you've hit rock bottom in your life and
you're like you've been brought back
up so it's just kind of like there's all
this multiple meaning that the
title has and i just think it's a
brilliant title so basically what
happens
so this kind of all goes on and he makes
friends with pastor jacobs like i said
he's very very popular in the town
everybody
loves him and then there's just a
terrible
horrible like random car accident
in which his wife and son are horribly
horribly killed after this point
uh the pastor begins to
lose his faith well he doesn't begin to
lose his faith he pretty much loses his
faith to a point where
he doesn't really he just thinks there's
really no purpose for anything anymore
or
it's almost kind of thing he's like if
there's a god up there he's just mocking
us
with with this random [ __ ] it's like you
know it's my wife and kid never did
anything to anybody i never did anything
to anybody
um you know so he's almost like he's
it's more than him being like quote
unquote angry at god but he basically is
just like there's
there's no meaning that nothing means
anything so
he has like a really bad like you know
period of grief obviously as you would
and then he gives a sermon one sunday
which in town lore becomes known as the
terrible sermon
because basically he comes on there and
he says all of these things he's just
like you know
what if nothing means anything and he
just has this big and everybody gets
like really offended and like starts
walking out and stuff because it's like
a very religious
uh you know like a methodist uh
community and they don't like all the
[ __ ] that he's saying and like i said
this part is in the 60s as well
so people were getting a lot more
religious than i guess so they were
uh you know so everyone gets offended
and walks out he ends up getting fired
and um leaves town now a lot of the
other townsfolk don't want to talk to
him after that but jamie still
uh you know suspects that he might be
right even though he's a little
kid so he still you know wants to
kind of give the olive branch of
friendship or whatever and uh the pastor
seemed to appreciate that and then
he sort of like you know goes off into
the winds or whatever
so then we skip ahead several years we
kind of talk about jamie's teenage years
how he discovered his talent for music
how he started getting into bands
and how that started to happen uh so we
kind of follow that and then
he starts taking uh he eventually ends
up as a heroin
addict um you know he's playing as a
session musician like i said he's in
several bands he's making a living at it
and he's touring with all these other
bands but
it's getting to a point where his
addiction is making him so unreliable
that he keeps getting fired
so when we jump ahead to i can't
remember what year it was it's
i think it's sometime in the 70s and he
has
uh pretty much hit rock bottom like i
said he wakes up in this fleabag hotel
um you know he's peed his bed and he's
you know having like [ __ ]
he wants to go and score and this band
has fired him and they've left him at
this motel because that's what they were
saying
and so he decides he's gonna go to this
nearby state fair carnival type of thing
and he's gonna get some drugs now while
he's there
he happens to come across his old buddy
uh pastor jacobs who was not a pastor
anymore but he's now he's working
uh a carne shy as they call it and it's
called portraits in lightning
and he does this amazing thing where
he takes a picture like he has this
old-fashioned looking camera
and he has somebody come up from the
crowd or whatever and takes a picture of
them with this crazy camera and makes
all this lightning
and then it sort of like it's kind of
hard to describe but it takes the person
and it puts them on this really big
screen
except it changes the color of their
hair and it makes them look all
glamorous and [ __ ] like that and then he
takes a picture of it like on a glass
plate and then you can keep the picture
right and nobody can figure out how he
can do it so it's almost kind of like
this weird
tesla situation because apparently he's
been
experimenting this whole time that him
and jamie have been uh separated
and has come up with some uh pretty
crazy [ __ ] but he's like
you know earning money like on the
kearney circuit doing these crazy
portraits now while this is
going on like i said jamie is kind of
jonesing for
heroin and he ends up passing out and
pastor jacobs who is not a pastor
anymore like i said so we'll just call
him charlie because that's what uh
that's what jamie calls him and uh he
basically rescues him and he takes him
back to his trailer
and uh he says that you know
in all the experiments i've been doing
with this electricity which he calls his
secret electricity
um i can heal you of your addiction now
this is a callback because back in the
60s
um they know that he's not entirely full
of [ __ ]
because he used his this electric gadget
that he had
invented and it he called it like a
nerve stimulator or something like that
to cure
jamie's brother conrad who had lost his
voice after getting like hit in the neck
with a ski pole or something like that
so um you know so pastor jacobs tried to
write
like write it off at the time it's just
like oh you know his loss of voice was
just psychosomatic i just like made him
believe
you know so like i said it's very much
the theme of this is just kind of like
faith and magic making things happen you
know placebos and things like that
but jamie suspects that he really did
heal him so
now when he meets him and he has like
the heroin addiction and you know pastor
jacob says
you know i will heal you of your heroin
addiction using you know my updated
uh experiment that i've been working on
with electricity and so since he has
that
experience of him healing his brother
back in the 60s
he agrees to do it although he is
reluctant
uh because he's not sure it's entirely
safe and he's not sure you know what i
mean
so uh so charlie is basically like well
if you
if i do this um you know you come with
me and be my assistant for a while
but he's like you can't hang out because
i'm kind of a loner
um i don't really want all of this
because he's still like kind of a broken
man because of the horrible [ __ ] that
happened him back in the 60s
he's never gotten over the death of his
family so
he's kind of like just drifting from
place to place jamie agrees
uh they do the lightning thing and
it does immediately heal his heroin
addiction like he tries to even give him
the bottle and he's just like no i'm
good like i don't i don't need it
anymore
and so it's like a miracle right but
then
jamie starts to have a couple of like um
weird
side effects let's call him that nothing
too
alarming really but he will
kind of like do [ __ ] like sleepwalk like
he'll wake up in the middle of the night
and he'll be like standing in the corner
of the room like stabbing his arm with a
fork or something like that
and it's like a little bit alarming but
charlie makes the point he's like yeah
but that'll probably fade after a time
he's like i've been doing these
lightning portraits which is a similar
kind of thing
and uh you know it's it wears off after
a little while so you'll be fine
and he's like it's just just think of it
like you know a side effect after get
after taking you know like a antibiotic
or getting a vaccine or something like
that it's like you know it'll fade it's
it's
it's fine and it's like way better than
having a heroin addiction right right
at this point like i said so the after
effects are a little upsetting but
nothing too
uh you know earth-shattering so jamie's
like okay fine that's fine
so then they separate once again because
as i said charlie's kind of like you
know i i work alone
and i'm gonna go on my way now but what
he does do
is he sets jamie up with a dude he knows
named hugh in colorado
who owns a music studio and he's like go
there tell him that i sent you and he
will give you a job
you know with the implication being that
he
had healed that guy of something too
which they do actually discuss later on
so he owed him a favor so jamie actually
cleans up his act he goes out to
colorado he starts working at this music
studio he
works up his way up to manager he's like
a session musician he works with like
famous people
so his life is like looking pretty good
as it goes on though like him and hugh
like several years go by
like i said everything's doing good he
has a job and then
they discover that uh you know all these
years later after he's been
cured the pastor is back again now he's
going by pastor danny i think
and he's doing like a tent revival they
find out about it
because they see it on the internet and
they're like what the [ __ ] it's like oh
he's back to those old tricks again now
he's healing people
you know at these big tent revival
meetings so they're like we
should probably go check this out and so
they decide to do that because it turns
out that hugh
who was also healed of something i can't
remember exactly what it was but he was
also healed of something by uh
by the pastor and that's why he owed him
a favor but he has weird after effects
too but his are different
he says that he sees he calls them like
prismatics
and he's like i see all these like weird
[ __ ] colors and at this point
when he said that in the book i was like
this is gonna go
in a lovecraft direction because it
reminded me very much
of remember when i did the review on
that movie x the man with the x-ray eyes
and i said that guy was like you know he
could see past everything
and when he was going more and more and
he was like his vision was getting
better and better
and he kept seeing like all these
shifting colors and you were meant to
you were meant to surmise that he was
seeing like beyond the bonds of like
the universe like parting the veil and
like seeing like other dimensions and
[ __ ]
and what was behind everything that's
essentially
what i suspect and that's kind of the
direction it goes in
like i said it's a very lovecraftian
existential
type of scary [ __ ] like what's like
we're piercing the veil of
what's behind everything like what's
behind like the secrets of the universe
and all that kind of stuff so it does go
in that direction
so yeah so he had started seeing all
these shifting colors but he's like it's
nothing
too bad but he's like and i haven't had
it for a long time
but they go to the tent revival and the
dude
seems to be healing people even though
some of the [ __ ] jamie's just like i
don't know some of this looks like
[ __ ] like fake
you know sometimes oh i'm taking the
tumor out and he's like that's obviously
like a chicken liver or some [ __ ] like
that
but some of this stuff seems kind of
legit now
at the tent revival hugh has another one
of his prismatics things
and it's like really really bad and he's
like not only did i see that but i also
saw this really horrible
vision of like people were like big ants
and it was just kind of thing
and then uh jamie had had like
nightmares previously about all his dead
family members and like with ants
crawling out of like a
cake or something and uh so he's kind of
like okay well we need to look further
into this
so what jamie decides to do is that he
becomes kind of obsessed with
looking into uh charlie slash
pastor danny's past and being like all
these people that he healed
you know did they have the same like
after effects like i had does it really
work
what the [ __ ] is going on because he's
starting to think that maybe there's
something sinister so he enlists
uh this girl who's like the daughter of
someone that works with him
and they're also kind of have like a
little romantic thing too but it's not
like a big
thing and so she decides she helps him
look up all of these people that the
pastor supposedly healed now a lot of
them
seemed like they were really healed and
a lot of them seemed like they were okay
but there was a not insignificant
percentage of them
that had uh some really unfortunate
after effects from the healing uh
including you know eating dirt one
person just went mentally
you know they they just went essentially
mentally comatose they just kind of like
stood there and looked at a wall
so there was enough there that they said
okay we need to find this dude now
and stop him from doing what he's doing
because he's
hurting people so that's essentially the
final third of the book
is basically jamie trying to find the
dude because he's kind of going into
hiding
like he did the pastor thing he made
like a [ __ ] ton of money like millions
and millions of dollars
so he can like move around at will and
like keep things secret
and he's still working on his
electricity and the point is that he's
basically trying to
as i said pierce the veil of death he
wants to see
what's beyond it if there's anything
beyond it and it all stems from
that long ago time when his family was
killed just in this random
stupid accident that was nobody's fault
and
him losing his faith in god and then
also
wanting to maybe even see if he could
see them again or see what was
you know see if they were still there if
they could be accessed and
see if god was real um basically so it's
just kind of like
like i said a very dr frankenstein mad
scientist
type of guy and i liked his character
because even though
he's ostensibly the villain like the of
the antagonist
he doesn't start out that way he
actually starts out as a lovely
person but as life goes on
and just kind of kicks the [ __ ] out of
him he becomes more and more
crazy and more and more obsessed with
finding out the secret of secrets of the
universe basically
so his his journey and jamie's are
almost kind of like parallel
and it's almost kind of like at the very
beginning of the book and i think even
on the
uh the back blurb it has like kind of a
an excerpt
where jamie calls the pastor
his fifth business meaning this person
that he met when he was a kid and it
just like the agent of change
like of his entire life and it's almost
kind of like these two characters are
linked over the years because he keeps
running into the dude
or you know like their fates are linked
because they met when they were uh
kids and it was some kind of some kind
of like connection that was made there
that can't be broken
so over the last third of the book jamie
is
sort of forced to work
with pastor danny or charlie whatever
you want to call him because he goes by
different names over the course of the
book
in his sort of final experiment to
pierce the veil like i said he sort of
gets blackmailed into it he's not super
happy about it
um and that's how the final third of the
book goes this book it's intere
this it's really interesting because the
first probably two-thirds of it
i don't know if i wouldn't call it a
horse it's definitely a horror novel
but it's not like a lot of the first two
thirds of it is basically just like
going through someone's life and all of
their kind of trials and tribulations
you know everybody that can relate to
you know
having like a drug addiction or getting
older like having your um
you know having family members die
things like that so it's just kind of
like there's a lot of that
and then with just these kind of hints
on the outset that [ __ ] is not
what it seems like and you know maybe
the afterlife isn't what you think it is
or maybe so it's like i said it's a very
existential dread type of thing but also
i think the character of jamie who
the whole entire book is told from his
perspective like it's in the first
person
he's such a great character that it's
very very
easy to just go along for the ride of
him talking about his life and talking
about these tragic things
so it's almost kind of like it's pretty
dark in some ways but it's not
dark in a way i mean it's just [ __ ] that
happens to like regular people it's like
basically [ __ ] happens the book you know
what i mean like the first two thirds
and it's not until the final third that
it goes full-on
like supernatural frankenstein lovecraft
type of [ __ ] where he's getting like all
these horrific visions of like what
could possibly be
beyond the out beyond the boundaries of
the universe or whatever
so it's that so i think it likes a good
balance between those two things
because like i said for a while i wasn't
really sure which way it was gonna go i
knew it was gonna go like once he
started talking about the colors and the
lights and everything i was like oh like
man with x-ray eyes
so i figured it was going to go like in
a lovecraftian direction which it did
but i wasn't entirely sure how that was
going to manifest itself so i really
really liked
how it uh sort of played out now it i
did feel like the end was a little bit
abrupt but that's like a very very minor
criticism
on the whole i just i love this book i
just thought it was so
it was such an easy read like i said his
character is just so
likable and he's so compelling and he's
so real
that you know it's very easy to just
follow him along this journey even when
they're doing like just regular teenage
[ __ ] or he's just talking about playing
in his band and
you know getting addicted to heroin how
you score and all this other kind of
stuff
so it's just kind of you know and
stephen king is writing obviously from a
lot of his own
life because he had a lot of addictions
as everyone knows and he's also
in a rock band i think they still play
rock bottom remainders it's him and a
bunch of other
authors and they just kind of get
together and play some gigs and stuff
so he's kind of writing about what he
knows um and writing about just life in
general and how life can kick the [ __ ]
out of you
so so i think that all of that kind of
comes through and makes this just like a
really genuine
read and it's a total page turn or two
because like i said you don't you're not
entirely sure where it's going so
i mean the whole time i mean this book
it's short for stephen king it's only
like 400 pages
it's only 400 pages stephen king's books
are usually these big door stops
but uh so i read it in like maybe like a
day and a half
maybe like it and you know that's not an
entire day but just like a few hours
here a few hours there
because i just i wanted to see what was
going to happen you know what i mean so
it's like a real page turner
but yeah so if you haven't read any of
stephen king's newer stuff because i
know there's a thing like with horror
fans and it's just kind of like
i always knew her stuff isn't as good
and blah blah which i guess to a large
degree
agree with that but i haven't read you
know i've just read like a smattering of
his newer things
and i didn't like some of them as much
as i liked
the his older stuff but this one
i think was definitely uh definitely a
winner this one is definitely
maybe like i don't know if i'd call it
like a return to form
but it's definitely one of i think it's
probably the best of the
of the new ones of his that i've read it
was the most compelling it had the most
interesting story
i really liked the homage to like old
mad scientist stuff
like old like carny kind of stuff i like
all the rock and roll stuff
and it's like pretty much like all of
the cool [ __ ] that he's into
like in all of the authors that he loves
he's kind of put all that in there so
it's almost kind of like a love letter
to all of that and i thought that was
like
but with also being its own thing you
know what i mean
so i really really liked that but yeah
it's like definitely
i'm really glad i picked this up because
like i said this is stephen king book
and i just saw the bookstore and i was
just kind of like oh hey haven't heard
of that one
maybe i should read it so i picked it up
and read it and yeah it's like really
really good i really really liked it a
lot
and it does seem like um i've read some
other reviews of it and a lot of people
also really seem to dig it so you might
also
so you know there it is it's revival by
stephen king came out in 2014
so if you haven't read it go and check
it out i highly recommend it
and i will see you guys on the next
homes of tear bye